We all have sick remedies that we swear by.
I mean, nothing feels better than a hot bowl
of chicken soup, right? Well, it turns out
that it may actually have an anti-inflammatory
impact, as it prevents neutrophils, a type
of white blood cell, from moving. And by slowing
down the movement of neutrophils, it prevents
the cells congregating in the lung area, relieving
congestion.
But you may have also heard the expression
‘feed a cold, starve a fever’ - so should
you only eat soup...sometimes? It turns out
this is only half true. In both cases you
should actually be eating nutrient rich food,
which gives your body the energy to heal itself,
and increases something called gamma interferon
- which is essential for your immunity against
both viral and bacterial infections.
So why not eat an apple? Because an apple
a day keeps the doctor away, right? Well...to
a degree! 100 grams of apple contain the same
antioxidant power as 1500 mg of vitamin C,
which has been shown to inhibit the growth
of both liver and colon cancerous tumours.
Their peels, which are rich in flavonoids
are also linked to a reduced risk of coronary
heart disease. So while it may be associated
with less visits to the doctor, and as a preventative
medicine for your overall health, it’s impact
on the common cold is still debated.
So what about just taking lots of Vitamin
C, whether in the form of lemons, other foods,
or pills? It turns out, in a double blind
study, it didn’t reduce the incidence of
the common cold. However, it did significantly
reduce the length of colds. This may be due
to the increased growth in T Cells, which
are white blood cells involved in your immune
response, as well as an increased production
of interferon, which causes virus-infected
cells to ramp up their anti-viral defenses.
If you’re in need of some immediate relief
for a cough or sleeping difficulty from a
respiratory infection, honey has your back!
Known for its antibacterial activity, It increases
the release of inflammatory cytokines, which
signal cells to repair themselves.
And garlic? Not only can it ward off vampires,
but it’s been shown to decrease the length
and severity of cold and flu symptoms. By
increasing the growth of Gamma-Delta-T-Cells
and Natural-Killer cells, it’s able to pick
up on invading pathogens and remove them more
effectively.
Ever try Echinacea? It’s one of the most
popular herbal supplements, and for good reason.
In a meta-analysis on 14 studies, Echinacea
decreased the odds of developing a cold by
58% and reduced the length of colds by approximately
one and a half days. It works as an anti-inflammatory
and similar to other remedies, influences
cytokine production in the body.
And while you’re at it, have a drink - with
a little alcohol. Seriously, some studies
have found that moderate amounts of alcohol
can help boost your immune system. But before
you crack a bottle open, consider that ‘heavy
drinkers’ were found to have the weakest
immune systems.
If all else fails, water, rest, and time are
surefire contributors to recovery.
So which sick remedies are just plain old
false then? We break down the top sick myths you
thought were true in our new AsapTHOUGHT video,
and use scientific research and evidence to
debunk them. Click on the screen or the link
in the description to see that video.
And hey - our book - which answers even more
of your burning questions - is almost out!
So if you haven’t got your copy yet, head
on over to asapscience.com/book and be the
first to get your hands and eyes on it!
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!